earning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
it is a dark and gloomy day in New York
and honestly I'm not feeling it today
but I have no choice because it is my
job and because it is officially the
two-year anniversary of the morning
toasts you guys that is so crazy
Jackie and I were just looking at our
time hops like all the photos we took at
our studio the day we started the toast
and that was our old studio if you're
new here and if you're new here like
honestly you just don't ever need to see
the first episode of the morning shows
oops okay you don't need to see the
first episode of the morning toast
mostly because it's like so full of
glitches that you probably couldn't even
decipher it - just like the looks and
the glam and it's just not on point you
know my outfit was cute but it was the
maybe months before I realized that I
needed a new chin and new lips and I
don't know when I look at the picture
what I'm more distracted by my big puffy
face or my tiny lips getting swallowed
by my jowls I don't know it was just it
was nothing of the sort
but you know it was like I look at that
day and those girls and I'm like those
are the bravest girls I've ever seen
those two girls actually I don't even
feel associated with them like I don't
really feel like I know them and I feel
really like inspired by their bravery me
too so yeah I agree there's a sense of
disassociation from that day that's that
set like that whole thing with our
little marquee letters that like you
didn't like but I really felt like they
were gonna make or break the show I like
I when Jackie like disagrees I usually
like side with Jackie but I was like no
I stood up for the letters I was like
Jackie these are it and how do you feel
now I think how many shows did we use
them for like four no like two maybe
honestly I look at it now and I'm like
oh that's mortifying but I don't know
what it would have looked like without
them so I can't speak on whether or not
I was truly wrong and there's something
iconic about them is their yeah is I
don't know I just only real ones will
know only we all ones will know I mean
it set us on this journey that has just
been so fabulous and as much as like we
don't know those girls we actually I
hate to tell you we are those girls no
and we could every here without that and
like there is a part of us that like
could do it again if we had to I really
don't want to so that's why even though
I'm in a bad mood today I'm not gonna
say anything that could offend anyone or
that could end us up starting over
because I'm done starting over I did it
once and to be honest I'm glad like it
got us here but whoa whoa
Jarett woof woof but it's been two years
of a great ride the toaster community
has just been so fabulous going on this
journey with us anyone who watched that
first day one episode we love you thank
you for sticking by us all this time do
you remember how many people were making
fun of us like during that livestream
the whole [ __ ] world and what's crazy
I mean it's not crazy but we said during
the show as like it's only gonna go up
for here from here because we can't go
any further down production wise or
reputation wise right like it can't get
any worse and we stayed good to our
promise yes only on up from here we
broadcast every morning from what looks
like heaven people ask if it's a green
screen because it's so heavenly it's and
I said to them no look in the bottom
left corner there are cars moving that's
how you know it's real and the show is
great we have fabulous merch like just
everything that's come out of the toast
we've had camp toast Network these
things that have would have never been
possible if we hadn't started the toast
and if nobody watched it so at the end
of the day like we could pat ourselves
on the back all we want but the fact
that people tune in every day is really
what makes the world go round
yeah and we can like Pat them on the
back all they we want but like they
wouldn't tune in every day if we weren't
fabulous so let's save ourselves a
[ __ ] pat on them okay wait also there
was opposed to in the toast after dark
yesterday like people do this every once
in a while and it's my favorite thing
like how did you first find out about
the toast and it's so random like there
was a lot of say yes to the dress
because that's just like obvious so no
that's not obvious that's so weird we're
not those girls either no we're not
those girls are also like I followed
girls on the job forever like I don't
even like and I know I haven't girls no
job but like I feel like because of the
toast I've like become Claudia so much
more than I become girls no job which
has always been my dream you know but so
many people like there was a bunch of
responses of people who said they found
us when Danielle Caroline came on
because I guess she just has a hat or
has a really different following than us
like yeah more college or I don't even
know but I thought it was an interesting
answer that is an interesting there's
always like the wake up with Taylor I
follow Jackie on Twitter like there are
always like classic answers but a bunch
of people and let us know I'm so curious
to know people said that when Danielle
Caroline came on as a guest and that's
why I think we'd second-guess ourselves
a lot with guests we're like is it worth
it but honestly it is because if it's
someone with a unique audience yeah and
it's always better when they are a
toaster themselves which he is which is
why I worked out oh also a bunch of
people said they found out about us like
one way or another
to the first episode and I just like
didn't like it and then like something
or whatever brought them back and it's
always like the second episode that
keeps them interested that's so
interesting because I was reading
something yesterday Oh someone a guest
companies have been doing this thing
where they put out like a little
internal memo and everyone in the
company like shares their favorite
podcasts to get them through the
quarantine and of course you know some
account manager who's fabulous loves the
morning toast and so she had to write a
description of what the morning toast is
and it's interesting to hear someone
else describe it she hit it nail on the
head watch the morning show live on
YouTube podcast follow ha but she also
said like it's really fun but it'll take
you a while to figure out their inside
jokes yeah and I think that's something
we struggle with is like wanting to talk
during the live show as as if everyone
listening is like day one toaster but
then also wanting to like welcome in new
people and I find myself like stopping
myself from talking and explaining which
is like boring to people who listen so
that's something I struggle with but for
sure that's that makes sense as to why
people maybe need one or two episodes do
I get in so if this is like if you are a
new quarantine watcher here are some
things that you need to know one the
biggest thing that you need to know is
that Claudia and I are sisters we are
blood sister we're not like sistas no
we're sisters
same mother same father grew up in the
same house grew up in the same house we
are sisters blood room we have two other
sisters too who I'm sure you're familiar
with by now ones whose is snitch but her
name is not snitch and she is not a
snitch call her and one who is Olivia
also important that I feel like a lot of
people might not know I am older than
Claudia also Ben is my husband not my
brother
and Theo is her son but he's actually a
dog not a human baby who couldn't be
here today I'm sorry it's raining and I
just don't like to take him out of the
house when it rains he causes such a
mess yeah just like so much ruckus so
much ruckus um my husband his name is
Zach but I call him names it means is
just a nickname that really just came
out of thin air much like a lot of the
other things that we say indeed right so
probably the number one most confused
question by new toasters is what does
scene mean and honestly it's not worth
coming into just know like we call
ourselves the Steen if you would like
love us you're also a Steen and the
vibes that we carried on the show which
is just like positive fun-loving
listening to music going out dancing
those are steamy
making memories that are gonna last a
lifetime that make you feel like you
made the most of your life with the
people that you want to spend time with
those are the steamy vibes yeah anything
else we need to clear up I don't know if
anyone like wants to drop a question oh
and also Claudia's son who is a dog we
call him dr. Theodore fat Chapman but
technically he is not medically trained
and did not go to medical school it's
hard for us to admit this because like
we see him as a doctor but he has
absolutely no medical qualifications his
whole conversation is like so offensive
so [ __ ] her like when you just called
Theo a dog before that was just I'm
telling him no it hurt me but like
sometimes we have to speak plain English
so also I read our podcast reviews and
there's like legitimate people who
thought forever that Theo was my actual
like human son yeah and while he is he's
her human son that's a dog who's human
yes but also at the ogee but you know
dogs fell backward he is God look at God
you guys and if you're hoping for more
background we did a patron episode a
while ago kind of answering like the
Internet's most confused questions about
us so if you want to go to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast you
can get access to that episode and
hundreds of others yeah and if you want
to get to know us better I actually saw
someone messaged me last night
responding to my beautiful Seder table
which will get it to UM saying that they
would love an episode about all of our
Jewish traditions and our Jewish
upbringing and there actually is a
patreon episode for that that's like
that state that staples button yeah sure
I'm episode 4 that is that the staples I
don't know like there's a oh I'm
thinking of there's a subgroup that no
but there so there's a button oh it's I
don't know okay but you know what I'm
saying yeah I think it's Apple there's a
blank for that yes whatever someone will
let us know
anyways patreon.com Sasha morning toast
if you really want to get to know us on
a personal level that's where it's at
yeah but other than that Happy Passover
everyone and Happy toast to your
anniversary how was we dinner Seder be a
zoom last night which was um I think
it's great I think it was as good
honestly it didn't feel that different
than like a normal Seder the tech was
good and it was as good as it could have
been I feel like our ancestors would
have been proud yes like here we are
dealing with the 11th plague and we
can't be stopped we're singing we had we
had so much like zeitgeist owners Nero I
was just gonna say I had so much qivana
like when I was praying like and usually
I say
it's like an hour before you actually
actually eat you have like sing and pray
and it's not ideal when you're sitting
at a dinner table and there's just no
food in front of you that's not how I
normally act at the dinner table
so you kind of rush through it and like
you're just like it's like you're at
Temple you're like let's just get it
over with
but last night I felt really connected
to the to the book and to God's ways and
you know all that he's done for his
people and if he you know if he had led
us out of the land of Egypt and not
giving us the Torah it would have been
enough yeah it really would have been
enough Dayenu
um I just I thought it was really nice
except it was [ __ ] exhausting yeah
the dishes when I so first think you
have to set up the table so many
different dishes you have to do the
seder plate like four different cups of
wine like by the time I was done with
our Seder then Zach and I joined his
family Seder I did two full satyrs I was
wiped the hell out oh and all the dishes
you know and we usually do our Seder all
together so not all of us have to do
individual dishes at our houses but like
I wanted to make it nice I didn't want
to do like paper plates like I needed to
be nice like I have respect for the
traditions and the heritage of our
people and that involved me like
scrubbing soggy wet food off of plates
until the break of dawn and it was just
so frustrated it was so difficult but
also I was realizing and no one I don't
think you could pick up on my inflection
in the Xoom but I think the our
ancestors actually predicted zoom satyrs
with the lyric he named me muhan zoom on
totally totally Zuma also I've been
seeing some other words people want
clarification on cleany the pastel
scenes when when scenes are running past
out today we are the pleased because
we're the pastel scenes so also we just
love like a pastel hue that's like
totally our aesthetic so those vibes are
called plainy vibe we're like our set is
pleading by because pastel it's bright
it's fun it's pastel and it's teeny
right you know and I feel like Easter is
like super Pelini and yeah I'm excited
for all of you who are gonna celebrate
zoom Easter soon if you need a like a
mood board aesthetic of what Pelini
vibes are it's just like Easter yeah
definitely also P John precious gem of
the man that was a name that was started
obviously for the doctor and the family
so precious your precious Jim your
position of the man and so and then
became an acronym and then
an acronym and now anyone who is
precious in this world is a P job or if
you're our woman a peach ow or if you
don't identify you're just precious
you're just precious so those are the
key terms I think everything else is
just sort of touching oh and some things
some things are here for a short time
and some some things are like forever
last grab grab a spoon which is like an
iconic part of our brand we don't really
say anymore because it's just a
mentality yeah but it was um when you
want to tell someone to like [ __ ] off
you tell them to grab a spoon and eat
your ass and then for short grab a spoon
because you can't be like telling your
co-workers to eat your ass unless you
want to get fired yeah so it's just like
an ad it's a way of life yeah you know
it's the mentality I just feel like I'm
not gonna be able to give this show my
all today like we were talking yesterday
about how we've been having so much
trouble sleeping and I think like I
cursed myself and how I said it
yesterday because I was up till 3:00 in
the morning with a [ __ ] migraine I
couldn't sleep tossing turning and Theo
had the audacity to sleep on the love
sack which like I didn't even tell him
to do but you raised that was his goal I
know but like when you're laying him
like up in bed all night like all you
want to do is have your son in your arms
and I just couldn't I did and I wasn't
even thinking about anything it was just
so boring and then I went to bed and I
had a migraine the entire time I was
asleep when I woke up I put two feet on
the ground and I still had a migraine
like I'm just it's not my day today at
all on the weather always affects my
migraines and today's such grainy
weather yeah today is one of those
season you know what today we feel like
such garbage that it's like I understand
how last Thursday we gave a show that
was so not positive we canceled Tuesday
Thursdays and we were just like we were
done because that's how I feel and then
on Monday we were like we take it all
back ya know like honestly I'm
regretting the decision to do Monday
Wednesday Friday like I'm so I don't
know I wanna like I don't know whether
it's better like show up every day and
like give 70% or like take time for
myself and then show up like three or
four days a week and give it a hundred
percent just given the current climate
not on a regular week given the current
climate and I think this is what we
learned when people gave us feedback
about the Monday Wednesday Friday
schedule said they would rather see us
every single day and have it be whatever
literally they said we could talk about
waxing our [ __ ] then have no show at
all so they would rather keep beasts you
sit here being tired you don't have to
give it all firing an all can and say
just fire them one you know yeah like I
just don't feel I feel like Kourtney
Kardashian like I need boundaries but I
also feel like it's been 12 minutes and
this F
it has already been hilarious and
husband yeah people like just I think
it's cuz it's the spirit of the toast
anniversary you know it's it's really a
historic day it is I mean that
definitely lifted my spirits a little
bit
yeah just like reflecting on how far
we've come and it's just a great time to
be a toaster I just les you're on the
toast anniversary like we were just so
happy and like we bought new dresses and
we had a party and like this year I'm
just like in my house
I know but next to that means that next
year we'll be so happy and buying
dresses and everything hopefully yeah
hopefully took an every other year thing
yeah but that means that the year after
will be her have should we dive in is
there anything else we need to discuss
there was no TV on last night no but I
would like to discuss our merge drop
because everyone is so excited so many
people got so many things and I just
want to give a few clarifications
because you are able to order your merch
from now until Sunday night and though
everything is unlimited quantity because
we are making everything it's made to
order when you order it we will make it
we're now reaching a point where so many
people are ordering certain items in a
certain size that the actual company
that makes the apparel they don't have
enough of those shirts so now size
medium tie-dye long-sleeve are sold out
not like because it was unlimited but
like the limit did exist eventually
right look at the company yeah so keep
that in mind that like there's a lot of
quantities of everything but it could
like and I think more tie-dye cell sizes
are going to sell out so if you do plan
on buying something I would buy it
sooner rather than later to make sure
that you get your size yeah but um
shipping till Sunday unfortunately no
International shipping given the current
postal climate and yeah that's it and
what's on my cam to a sweater today but
I just looked so ugly in and I'm just
really feeling like oh that's better I
know I'm just feeling so like not good I
can't explain that like I physically
emotionally mentally like I'm just not
having a good day I mean I totally I
totally understand maybe I'll try and
think of some suggestions that could
like turn your frown upside down yeah
you know I don't know if I just like
need a nap or I need to cry you look
like you're like tears in your eyes do
you want me to just let it out no no you
want keep it suppressed so press okay
cool well I guess that's as good a time
as any to get into the five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and I have absolutely nothing to say I
do not protest it is time it is time
okay well I think that for the first
story is gonna just like you know give
you something to say is it Ellen its
Ellen Ellen DeGeneres sparks backlash
after joking a self quarantine is like
quote being in jail one of Ellen
DeGeneres's jokes backfired this week
after some people called her out for
comparing self quarantine during the
corona virus pandemic to being in jail
the popular host who like many TV hosts
has made her show virtual amid stay at
home orders said the comment while
broadcasting to viewers from her home on
Monday she said quote one thing I've
learned from being in quarantine is that
people this is like being in jail is
what it is it's mostly because I've been
wearing the same clothes for ten days
and everyone here is gay so people don't
get me wrong I'm the first person to
like hop on the bandwagon against Ellen
because I think that people need to know
that she is most likely the devil but I
kind of think Twitter like overreacted
like I I understand that there is a
potential insensitivity um just like
given her her privilege and like she's
in a fifteen million dollar mansion in
Montecito like I get I get people's need
to be upset with this but like to be
honest it like wasn't even that funny of
a joke and like I really didn't find it
that offensive and like I just think
people are being like overly sensitive
here and I'm the first person to point
out Ellen and just like overall general
celebrity hypocrisy but I like I didn't
think it was that big of a deal but I
did see like a totally random tweet like
unfounded like no proof that this is
true but like it definitely made me
think like it's something that could be
true that like the writer who wrote the
joke because you know Ellen obviously
doesn't write her own jokes got fired
I'm sure someone is I mean hearing the
kind of boss that she is from that other
Twitter read like someone took the fall
for this and I agree if this was anyone
other than Ellen if it was someone that
I liked I'd be here defending that first
morning oh my god if this was tracing
we're gonna be like you guys don't
understand comedy when it's Ellen I'm
like you hold yourself and other people
and your writers will to other people to
such a high standard like yeah so it's
like hate to see I don't even care
enough about Ellen to like get mad about
this because to be honest it just like
wasn't even a funny joke like this is
what the world's best comedy writers are
putting together how sad but mostly
gonna say
hold on I had a really good point to
make about Ellen hmm hmm it's not my day
okay well succumbs actually I actually
want to talk about something that I saw
on Prop crepe Twitter obviously that
kind of relates to this because Lady
Gaga did an interview and she said
something like so poignant about how and
why celebrities are missing the mark on
this okay and this is what she said um
while promoting her upcoming coronavirus
relief concert with global citizen on
The Tonight Show
the singer explained why she takes issue
with people like herself and host Jimmy
Fallon using the unifying phrase of
quote we're all in this together during
uncertain times
she said quiet quote while I think the
sentiment is nice I also think that the
fight I'm in or that you're in right is
very different than the fight of a woman
that is in perhaps an abusive
relationship and has a child and lost
your job and can't feed her kid and
can't feed herself and also can't get
the help that she needs because she's in
a violent situation so she did obviously
not meaning specific celebrities but
it's like when you say we're all in this
together it's like no you're in
something far different than what
someone else is in yeah and and she's
right like the sentiment is obviously
nice but there's just this like obvious
hypocrisy that everyone besides
celebrities is like acutely aware of and
their lack of self-awareness it's just
more than ever just so obvious and I
just I'm like loving how people are not
into it like I'm loving the rejection of
just like celebrities using their
platform which is always something
they're like pressure to do and I feel
like a lot of the time celebrities speak
about things or speak on things just
because they feel like they have to not
necessarily because they like to feel
passionate about it and this is just so
this is just a weird time where
literally nobody needs to hear from
celebrities like I don't need to hear
from Ellen I don't need to her to do her
show while her producers like outside
six feet away like it's not funny yeah
at all yeah it's just not really but
even to like what we're experiencing
during quarantine is different from what
Ellen's experiencing but it also might
be different from what your experience
of course everyone's saying we're all in
this together like we all have this same
struggle of just trying to like you know
practice health care at home like people
have real problems and they don't want
to hear from celebrities talking
nonsense especially like
whose recently become just such a
polarizing figure especially on Twitter
and I love it yeah I do I think I think
it's important for people to be honest
about their experiences you know I
totally agree
so anyways and then obviously like the
most glaring hypocrisy of it all is that
the picture is going around of Ellen's
house right and it's like oh that's
that's prison and so where are some some
people are in the comments saying you
know oh that's not a big deal it's a
joke like it's funny I don't get why
it's a big deal and then some there are
some tweets going around saying quote
except that people in jail can't
practice social distancing don't have
enough water or toilet paper and are
going to die at exceptional rates from
covin 19 except for that Alan your
quarantine experience is just like being
in jail yeah no that's what I'm saying
like there are definitely ways to take
this joke sideways but I'm usually not
in favor of doing that but it is Ellen
and I'm I am looking for the comeuppance
of Ellen so I'll let this one slide yeah
yeah okay I just can't believe it like
it's never been more obvious to me that
Ellen isn't funny if you've ever watched
her episode of comedians in cars getting
coffee hosted by Jerry Seinfeld where he
just like sits in cars and gets coffee
with comedians and they're just really
themselves and you could like see how
certain comedians like having a presence
on stage and others are like super quiet
like every comedian is different because
when they're on stage like it really is
an act and it's so interesting to see
comedians that are like genuinely just
like funny people like Tracy Morgan's
episode like he was just going to a
diner and everything he did was so funny
and that to me is like a funny person
but Ellen's been on the air for like 15
years and she's had people writing her
jokes for 15 years and she's never
really had to be funny like even her
stand-up special which had professional
jokes written by it but it was really
all on her performance like it was not
funny and her and comedians and cars was
like the most letdown I've ever been
about like a funny person like there was
nothing funny about it she takes herself
so seriously and you really saw what it
was like for her not to like have a
script yeah for the first time in 15
years I don't know if I've watched it or
maybe it was just that forgettable
because I pretty much seen all the big
episodes yeah and like why wouldn't you
watch Ellen but it's on Netflix if
anyone wants to check it out it's just
it's so disappointing interesting and I
don't even think she's that funny like
with her team of writers
yeah it's clearly Twitter doesn't either
it's not for me no it's not for me but
it's for a lot of fee but it's like it's
like daytime humor and I get that but
like she is before before she was Ellen
she was a comedian she is a comedian so
you would expect her to still be funny
but I guess we
just expecting a little too much okay
next up Jennifer Eden of Real Housewives
of New Jersey reveals her coronavirus
diagnosed six Jennifer Eden says she
tested positive for coronavirus this
week the attest her doctor husband
brought home for her she said that her
symptoms started last week when she felt
quote extreme fatigue but no fever she
had so she asked her husband built a
plastic surgeon to bring home a test
which he did he was reluctant at first
because quote I didn't have the normal
symptoms like a fever or a heavy cough
so by day two or three I think it was I
insisted he bring home a test anyways it
turns out that she is positive and she's
self isolating and taking care of
herself that's I mean if you think about
it like its its heart like when you're
living in quarantine you forget about
like the normal world like celebrities
and and whatever but she's a real
housewife of New Jersey New York is like
one of the biggest hop it's like it was
only a matter of time before real
housewife of New York or New Jersey got
it yeah just give in like geographical
locations yeah so any other housewives
have it oh you know who has it I'm Chris
Lee Todd chrisley Oh interesting yeah
and his daughter put up the longest
Instagram caption that I actually read
and it was like not proofed by a
publicist and it was just like the
craziest rant I ever read in my life I
wasn't sure what the well he with the
message was an older fella and he was
hospitalized but like she was just like
she was writing her her caption and then
with everything she thought that someone
could take sideways she immediately
after that sentence like rebutted like
it was such a weird defense imagine but
it was really sad like he's a
grandfather he was hospitalized I
believe he's returned home and that he
is doing better but um it was like
supposed to be a sad post but it ended
up being just like weird infusing that
is weird and confusing social media in
the age of quarantine is just weird and
confusing um but another current virus
diagnosis and death that's actually
really sad but it harks back to an old
viral story that I think you'll remember
yeah the husband of the viral grandma
who accidentally invited the team to
Thanksgiving died from corona virus so
Wanda Dench the grandma could the
grandmother who won the Internet over
after she accident accidentally texted a
Thanksgiving invite to an unknown
teenager and had him over for dinner is
mourning the death of her husband Lonnie
Dench so um
Wanda texted Jamal just saying that she
has a plate for him for Thanksgiving and
then he
was like who is this and she was like
it's your grandma and he was like send
me a picture it wasn't his grandma and
she wasn't his grandkid but they still
spent medic giving together and now they
do that every year together but her
husband has passed away from coronavirus
which is really sad so sad I just keep
seeing such sad things about like older
people like who are having to die alone
it's like literally the saddest thing
ever
mm-hmm like people saying bye to them
over the phone that's so sad
it's so sad like today it's just dark
I'm just not feeling it like at all I
understand so I'll hit you with a
positive news for some sports fans out
there so this is actually some good news
you can share with your husband okay
because the NBA and ESPN have finalized
plans to televise a game of horse
shooting competition with sorry depart
Chris Paul Trey young zach lavine are
among those who will participate the NBA
announced on Thursday so the players
will be playing from their houses but
like they'll have to do like shopping
their house it horse that we all know
hor SC you know you make one yeah you
get a letter again letter yeah exactly
so that will be airing on ESPN Wow we've
come so far have we though no literally
I used to play horse honestly horse was
my like least favorite game because
basketball is so hard like a girl who's
always been short because we're short
it's just never been my sport like I
feel traumatized thinking of all the
times like I ever played basketball at
camp yeah I didn't make the basketball
team in the eighth grade but all my
friends did oh I always meet basketball
team because I was always like a point
guard cuz I was pretty quick okay but
you know and just think naturally I
thought it yeah of course you really are
thanks but I just like don't do anything
well I guess now I'm peloton you guys
yesterday we did a group peloton class
with the Pella toaster so there's a
peloton pace obviously quote not quote
hit there's a subgroup for that the
Pella toasters are the peloton toasters
and we all did the greatest showmen ride
together yesterday at 4 o'clock there
was over 200 toaster there toasters in
it I got so many high-fives I couldn't
keep up with high-fiving everyone back
hmm I hit my personal record for a
30-minute class and so many other
toasters too did too and it was so much
fun we'll definitely do it again I know
four o'clock on a Wednesday wasn't the
best time for everyone but I had to get
ready for Seder so that was that was one
of my peaks of the week
for sure well I'm hoping that this game
of course that's televised that keeps
been you know busy and away from me for
at least an hour and away from the
PlayStation leaving the courts out and
away from just like making a mess and
like pretending to clean it up but then
like I actually have to go in and clean
it up I actually heard this song on Mike
Lawrence teens playlist that snitch
contributed to and it's called quite
miss home and it's about a man who
misses how he didn't appreciate how his
wife swept the floor but then he walked
in with his shoes and how she did the
dishes and cook for him and I was like
this is the sweats gonna be me this is
the song of quarantine oh I also have to
issue a correction about yesterday I was
talking a lot about Ben's roast and you
know I speak a lot about my relationship
with Ben on here knowing that he's not
gonna hear it I assume that this is a
safe space but when you guys go and like
message Ben and tell him what I say like
I just wanna let you know like that's
not cool of you and like I thought like
it was you know hos before Bros but I
guess not
so I get home and Ben's like what'd you
say about my roast and I'm like all I
said was that like I knew I was being
unreasonable and asking you not to make
it but like it was a crazy thing for you
to do but I just have to say like it was
so delicious like I was wrong looked
phenomenal off the boat like I was
totally wrong but I just wanted to point
out like thanks to those snitches who
like ran until my husband when I said
about guys the first rule of toaster
dummies snitches ain't yeah like I do
the show every day under the impression
that Ben is never gonna see it no one
say anything crazy yes oh my god like
the sod yeah no he literally never
watches it and like now if I didn't I
mean the impression that my husband
would see it I would say my rose is my
husband Wow my husband did something so
fun I love Ben it was so wonderful no I
literally want to kill him well he took
out that trash at one time he did not
help with one lick of a dish last night
my husband helped and it was it was
helpful I put the whole thing on my back
it's crazy when you ask for help you
know yeah well I ask all the time I just
don't get it
really I begged delayed I asked I get it
but it's hard for me to ask cuz you know
what I'd rather put in my ear pods and
do it myself
no I asked and then he's like honest
when he's a Gorger I'm like Jim really
gonna make me ask again
take the [ __ ] trash out he's like
always on his phone he's like I'm like
Ben he's like I'm coming in he like
walks down the hallway really slow with
in his underwear like on his phone I'm
like well you just um like wiped down
this counter what and looks why I
already like asked like dug deep down
inside myself that's to ask for helping
like you're gonna make me do it not once
twice I mean you know that my greatest
pet peeve in life is repeating I know I
know so between that and asking for help
I couldn't do the two together it's so
frustrating so it's not that he's like
not willing to do it he's just like so
you know what I don't even gonna say it
because you guys are gonna run into yeah
I'm him what I said
totally I can't believe it like we've
come to that right no purpose two years
some can't trust ya like I'm like cuz he
said something I'm like did you watch
the toast like it was shocking I was
like mad at him but I was like impress
him I got my god he's like no like a
bunch of toasters DME I'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me that's [ __ ] crazy
Zack actually was watching Ben's story
like he literally cracks it I think Zack
has been the number one fan and the
exact gives him a big head and then Ben
comes home like think he's the funniest
person in the house and like I'm sorry
like it's it's me for sure but Zack was
like wow do you see this roast but I
mean I'm like yeah how dare he I was
like I don't know but if I were Claudia
I would feel like that's just so
disrespectful when they have a house
full of food and their fridge already
doesn't have space why do you need a
roast thank you it was like oh I didn't
think of it like no but it was so good
like I actually and I hate leftovers
it's like my thing like I don't like to
eat cold Tupperware food but I did save
it and I probably will heat it up for
lunch it's it was so good and it would
have been great with some rice but
currently we're not eating rice because
of Passover and that's what I'm really
like most upset about today like that's
why I tears in my eyes like I'm not
gonna have rice yeah that makes sense
like even this morning I was like she's
like thinking what we should have for
lunch and I'm like let's have tacos but
I can't no hmm yeah I'm using these
eight days to kind of get in shape a
little bit I'm still bloated from dinner
last night I don't know what I ate but
like my stomach is gargantuan gargantuan
gargantuan also if someone does snitch
on men today I'd be like okay cool take
his phone find out who it was and we're
putting you on blast totally putting you
on blast that's like some girl want
snapchatted picture of her titties too
been like not someone who knew like a
fan and I literally was about to post
her titties on my Instagram I'd be like
who's ever titties these are like I'm
coming to your house that's literally
revenge for yeah I know so that's why I
didn't do it but I did message her back
I mean like hi this is Claudia Ben's
wife and I'm gonna need you to put your
TIG old bitties away before I come to
your house and take them away
but also that was so long ago and it
hasn't happen to know what hasn't
happened since because we don't really
[ __ ] with snapchat but actually okay you
know I was just gonna say something but
then it's gonna like jinx
I'm not gonna say it are you ready for
our fifth and final story a little more
good news okay
Perry pays for all groceries for the
elderly at 73 stores amid coronavirus
pandemic this is Harry and this is now
precious gem of a man this is the
situation you would use it in P John
Tyler Perry there's so many things about
this that make me happy one is that like
in a time where I'm literally hating
everything celebrities are doing like
this makes me not only not hate Tyler
Perry but like love him more - there's a
lot of ways like celebrities can be
advocates and to me this is just such a
pure way like not only to pay for
people's groceries but like to know like
to go to a store during the elderly
shopping hours and like it was just so
much thought put into this like I think
this is so so sweet the TV and movie
mogul paid for the groceries of all
elderly shoppers at 44 Kroger stores in
Atlanta Georgia his hometown state as
well as 29 winn-dixie stores in his
native New Orleans during the hour
reserved for older customers amid the
corona virus pandemic so I'm sure he
just called them up and said here's my
credit card number it is covered for
this one hour that is so like really
like so thoughtful and so sweet
so fawful and so sweet and like such a
great idea and i feel as though if there
are any celebrities out there who from
the bottom of their hearts like want to
do good or just like want people to
think they're doing good whatever you
know the ends justify the means agree
this is a great thing to do call up
those grocery stores say it's on me and
then maybe link it to your publicist I
don't even care if you do I don't care I
will report I will report on it if you
do it with a happy cheery face
yeah we're just called Tyler Perry and
be like you know do it again I'll give
you here's 100 grand
I wouldn't how much all that cost yeah
not that much no not that much older
people are just like so cute they're so
simple - they're so sweet and they don't
even eat so much didn't even know they
really don't they don't mean much no
that's really really sweet I love Tyler
Perry he's always doing the right thing
of course he's like really one of the
very few moral compasses of Hollywood I
completely agree
remember that terrible story about the
guy from The Cosby Show
yeah Trader Joe's who worked at Trader
Joe's like there was this tweet that
went viral like oh who's got who's been
the Cosby Show he's bagging groceries at
Trader Joe's like okay yeah he needs a
job and it was just it was job shaming
and Tyler Perry ended up casting him in
a movie I love to see it love to see it
okay well those are our five stories
let's recap Confessions of a Teenage
Drama Queen because I did finally watch
it and it aged pretty well there were
parts of it that I liked wanted to die
but I never really realized like the
I don't know what the right word is but
like she really was such a drama queen
she was I mean she took herself so
seriously the movie is like kind of so
brilliant like this character that they
wrote for her even the things that she
wore and like just the work just I mean
her outfits were fabulous her outfits
were fabulous like even when she was
like morning's to wolf in the courtyard
and reliable and like the balloon sink
and she's like symbolically of course
you know she's such a drama queen and
honestly it really highlights like
Lindsay Lohan's incredible acting
abilities like it was fantastic she was
fantastic and she really is an
incredible actress the whole the whole
movie and she was a triple threat she
was dancing singing and acting yeah and
also just like being hilarious the movie
is so good they really like stuck with
me from a young age yeah and I always
have a pit when I watch it because you
know everything goes wrong in New York
and like it just gives me a pit when she
like leaves the money on the train but
then it all goes right you know who was
the worst was Ella because she had
lovely parents like she just made her
parents out to seem like the devil and
they were like you want to go to the
concert like why don't you tell us like
they had the means to get her there and
they were just like so lovely and
understanding and I just thought she was
like such a wet blanket the whole time
and yes but Lola did was like we are
lying about her parents like they
finally make it to Stu Wolff's house and
she doesn't go inside at first
oh yeah it's like come on take this out
on her later also when I watched the
movie like the first time as a kid I was
like how could they go to New York to
the concert like and then her parents
even letting her go I thought that was
so crazy but now it's like these girls
are like 15 16 years old they just want
to go to a concert it's so pure what's
the big deal they live in New Jersey
it's just a train ride away the biggest
problem I had with the movie is the
scene where they post the play parts and
everyone run and like I get they wanted
to get there first but like it wasn't
gonna change anything so I didn't
understand why they were like so for
Klimt to get their first Lex and making
such a mess with the janitors who were
waiting in Sunday janitors worked so
hard let them in early and like throwing
the tapes in the trash like they
literally just did you a favor no and
also they knew that they wanted to be
the first one there right in either of
them were sneakers oh right and like
Megan Fox like dressed like a secretary
Oh terrible Lola with her clunky heels
but Megan Fox saw that scene where
they're doing dance dance revelution and
Lindsay Lohan's burning that like Nick's
get up she looks so cute it's so cute
also it's crazy that in the whole
yeah I guess lindsay lohan and megan fox
didn't go far but like Alison Pill has
become one of like the most respected
actors Alison Pill Ella she has yeah she
was at the Oscars like a few years ago
she's did not show the newsroom why he's
like actually he's a real actress yeah
good she was so good at playing a
[ __ ] wet blanket playing a thirty
year old high school student yeah yeah I
mean I didn't even know that yet no it's
interesting to watch all these movies
back and see like what major movies like
did for certain people like sometimes
you watch these movies and like the
stars became nobodies like we think of
sleepover like Alexa Vega is a glorified
influencer but like she's homework but
spongebob is everything of his work yeah
he what's his name Evan Peters
he's like a such a well-respected actor
yeah that's why I like watching these
movies back is just in brie Larson like
brie Larson out acts Alexa Vega and Sara
Paxton yeah like who we thought when we
were kids like was out the number one
alpha what happened to her she was so
fabulous I just looked her up on
Instagram she's still like so pretty and
just like selling fabfitfun boxes which
you absolutely love to say yeah you
really do it's all you want for like
your former teen tristar's no of course
it was like Monica Potter
um what oh the another another part of
the movie which I thought to be so funny
was when I when the movie first started
and we see her mom for the first time I
keep thinking how the landlord from
kimmy schmitt should have played the mom
but the landlord plays the drives ijen
the drama teacher walks in and it's she
did such a good job she's a chameleon
that no I think that's her I don't I'm
not familiar with all of her work but
like I think that's her best work yeah
she's in that she's in Kimmy Schmidt
she's in Hunters she's in so much random
stuff she's actually a fabulous actress
whose name I will never learn is it
Shirley unclear hmm also like the
opening credits of the movie like I
think the artistry was like so well done
you know it's a little dated but it's
pretty an age fine
yeah I think it's a great movie I
absolutely love it um I also watched
more episodes of Punk'd on kwibi and
they did the Sabrina carpenter one and I
have to say it's fabulous
really it was maybe my favorite one oh
my god I have to watch I think that's
how I'm gonna spend my weekend on cry by
cry by yeah I also I've started I
continued to watch Chrissy's court and
honestly I can't get through it like I
find it infuriating that like she's such
a bad judge she would know it's so
I see it's like I really important teen
like don't have enough hours in the day
to do all the things that I want to do
that's crazy it's not I think it's also
because we moved the show back so like I
get home and it's like 2 o'clock and
then I like to peloton around like 4 or
5 like so I can make it out in time for
the 7 o'clock cheer which by the way I
hope all your cities are doing the 7
o'clock healthcare workers cheer because
it's so awesome I live in a pretty even
though I live so close to your like I
live in a totally different area
you just live no no it's because you
don't live on the main drag you live on
like the back side of the building
yeah it's actually more desirable
because you don't hear the honking and
the ambulance but I also don't hear the
7 o'clock train I don't hear what seven
o'clock share I say it's even worth
venturing out like walk cos I have a
roof deck oh yes well go there at 7
o'clock it's really cool to see actually
I would love to see it and when we were
on the zoom last night at 7:00 everyone
was like do you hear the cheer I'm like
no no even if I opened a window I
wouldn't hear it you know where you'd
hear it from here oh we should come here
at 7 o'clock here everything what else
did i watch yesterday Oh more One Tree
Hill
I finished the second season it was
fabulous need to know who burnt down Dan
Scott motors and I'm really enjoying
like having a show and Ben likes it too
so it's annoying cuz I can't watch it
during the day because Ben's working but
it's nice to have like something
together that is nice to have yes a can
I keep trying to like do that like every
night he asked me to watch hurts your
jewel and it's just not the right time I
just don't have enough time I'm so busy
with all of my new hobbies when Richard
Jewell um like came out in theaters it
was obviously like a movie that looked
great but I just I can't get myself to
watch something so sad like Richard
Jewell himself like looks so pathetic
like with the way just in the trailer
like he they just made him out to be
this like nish beginner you know what I
mean like this like weeny and like this
neba and I just I don't know what the
story is but I just know that like the
media frames him or he actually did it I
don't know what I don't know what sadder
like does the media frame him and ruin
his life is he a bad guy oh the story
which is why I have to watch a movie I
just feel like I it's a movie that I've
really wanted to see it was in theaters
for five minutes and I missed it and now
it's on demand like I just can't find
the time to watch it I don't know and
also parasite is apparently on Hulu now
and I have to watch that but you like
sitting down to watch a like a
award-winning movie it's hard Hulu is in
terms of selection like turning into
like a real frontrunner during these
quarantine times but at least on my fire
stick
the app is so awful and like not
user-friendly and like literally like
pause one tree like go make dinner or
something and then it literally takes me
back to my home screen I'd go back into
hello and I'm two episodes behind like
it's it just doesn't acknowledge my
pause it's so frustrating yeah it has a
terrible memory and it's like always
assuming I'm somewhere that I'm not yeah
and I'm like weren't you here weren't
you watching with me how hard is it he's
actually harder for you to pick an
arbitrary spot to put me on than to
remember where I thought it's almost
like someone's on my profile like two
episodes behind me all talking with your
life yeah but so we're not gonna assign
the trust movie of the day because
there's so much to watch tonight we have
new Real Housewives of New York and
Keeping Up with the Kardashians so
excited which we will recap tomorrow and
then we'll assign some toast content of
the weekend on Friday so tonight that
your homework is Kardashians and we're
Honi we're Romi is the one podcast
reviewer one there were actually more
than one so roni roni so yeah watch that
if you haven't gotten your March go to
shop morning toast calm the merchants or
is open till Sunday with pretty much
unlimited stock given a few limitations
here and there
unfortunately no international shipping
and all of our like our merch store with
all of our items that are constantly in
stock is not open because that warehouse
is closed so just the spring merch is
available I got a bunch of questions
about that ya know it has to be done
separately when the spring closes our
other stuff will go back up but right
now it is all spraying all the time and
you know I think that's something that
like if you're feeling down and you're
toasty as hell um a little spring merch
for cheer you right up so thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
Tosa millennial Morning Show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio I Heart Radio cash box all the
places whoever you listen to podcasts
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys very much we hope you have a great
day and we'll see you tomorrow thanks
for tuning here guys two years guys two
year guys